Welcome back everyone Eternals assemble.
They're actually doing the legit avengers
assemble stuff in the trailers now, so there's
a bunch of Easter eggs here.
Also because they call themselves gods people
thought of them as gods I'll explain which
gods they actually were based on inside the
marvel universe.
And just in general how Gods work inside the
MCU.
Because there are legit gods that do exist.
If you're brand-new to the channel, be sure
to subscribe to get all the videos is only
getting a crazier for the rest of the year.
This is just the beginning, but is addressing
some of these bigger new trailer scenes but
ikaris literally says
eternals assemble referencing
Capt. America's avengers assemble during endgame.
There was that whole see in the first teaser
trailer where they sit around the dinner table
literally talking about who's going to be
on that Next avengers team.
I was he they live so long they sit around
watching humans evolve over time.
They watch the events of the infinity saga
movies.
But didn't get involved because it didn't
involve deviants every explain the thanos
of it all in my previous Eternals videos about
why they didn't get involved with him even
though he does carry the deviant gene.
But as you can see there clearly aware of
all the major avengers characters and the
events of Avengers Endgame.
The reason why they're using so much avengers
footage in this is because are kind of on
the slide trying to let you know that some
of these characters will show up during Avengers
five and crossover that's why that is harping
so much on these scenes of the trailer sort
of convey this here we go again kind of situation
where it's like we used to be gods to these
people because were so powerful they didn't
understand who we were.
They didn't understand the celestials.
But now Salma Hayek ajak character is saying
because it was going to happen with the emergence
this to Celestial this going to emerge from
earth in the celestial host threatening to
come back and judge earth.
People will think of us is gods again in present
day.
The funny thing about that.
Like I said, there are gods that exist in
the marvel universe people of earth know exactly
who Thor is.
And they think of him as a God.
So this is the first time that people in present
day have reckoned with the concept of actual
gods existing there's also that other scene
of a jet communicating with the celestials
and aeration the judge and that astral cosmic
way that you also see Sersi doing in the other
trailers when she's getting ready to communicate
with Erickson the judge in the celestial host
like it looks like she's standing in outer
space.
But really this is more
like celestial communication
where they're basically
communicating telepathically
with them usually only one of the Eternals
is capable of doing that at any one time and
they just convey the wishes of the celestial
host to the other Eternals, you also see some
new footage of the deviants breaking free
from their prison where the Eternals trapped
them.
This also ties in with a lot of the myths
about their characters to become the inspiration
for different gods different
religions, particularly
Greek gods and Greek mythology and they have
a very guardians of the galaxy inspired scene
with Druid when they're back on the ship after
they first come back together and present
day is very similar to the guardians of the
galaxy 12% of a plan seem like what's your
plan.
I got a plan 12% of a plan.
Like how we get to stop this giant celestial
from emerging from earth and destroying it
how you stop the deviants from trying to kill
humans and how we can a stop the celestial
host and Erickson the judge from coming back
in judging planet Earth and wiping all life
from it and starting over, so just explained
gods in the marvel universe in which gods
these people are the inspiration for within
the MCU or the Marvel cinematic multiverse
everyone to think about it now.
Thank you very much Loki and Sylvie in the
Kang multiverse war.
There different levels of gods so you have
little g gods like Thor, Odin Hela even ego
the living planet, who is a celestial inside
the MCU canonically now calls himself a little
G God.
Even though by himself.
He's way more powerful than characters like
Thor, then you have the Captial G God.
So there is an actual one true God in the
marvel universe.
But were probably never going to see him inside
the MCU at any point.
Because he just way to overpower he's called
the one above all, he also has a counterpart
this called the one below all, who sort of
a much more powerful version of what you would
consider the devil even though the actual
devil you think of when you think of a Redskin
horn devil you think of Mephisto he's more
of a little G God, you think of being on the
level of someone like dormammu or the celestials
crazy cosmic level characters, but still not
quite as powerful as the one above all.
If you haven't seen any my Thor love and thunder
videos.
Christian Bale is going to be the Gorr the
god butcher of the MCU and gore basically
goes around killing anyone that calls himself
a god bigger or lesser inside the MCU.
So like some gods are more powerful than others.
Obviously, but he doesn't discriminate he
goes around killing all of them because he
feels like the gods no longer care about the
people who worship them.
So he's basically cleaning house.
So after Thor love and thunder.
There will be way fewer gods in the MCU the
way actual gods like Thor, Odin Hela exist
is that in the comics is a little bit different
Asgard for instance in the comics is in a
place that you could just fly to if you had
a spaceship you need use the bifrost to get
there, because it exists in a different dimension
in the MCU they portray them more like highly
evolved beings kind of like the celestials.
Not all asgardians have the same cosmic power
that Thor, Odin and Hela have for example
though.
Like Thor, Odin Hela they drawn this cosmic
universal power.
The same way that the celestials draw cosmic
power.
Everybody kind of gets their power from a
slightly different place.
Like Doctor Strange draws power from other
dimensions chaos magic is another completely
different type of magic the beings that are
capable of calling themselves gods have some
connection to a cosmic power that they can
draw on that makes them more powerful than
other highly evolved beings as I said though
the eternals characters became the inspiration
mostly for the Greek pantheon.
There were a couple others to eject became
the inspiration for the Aztec God and the
Inca God in these trailers you see them standing
around all these Mesoamerican pyramids.
That's probably where some of these legends
about her were created, ikaris became the
inspiration for the legends about the Greek
ikaris like don't fly too close to the sun
is even a moment in the trailer where he you
see him flying and attacking from the sun
from the deviants line of sight Makkari became
the inspiration for the Greek god Mercury
because of her speed Sersi became the inspiration
for the Greek legend of Circe from Homer's
Odyssey the daughter of Helios who could transform
her enemies and she spends a lot of the Odyssey
story going around transforming people and
animals during the trailer you see her transmute
the bus into flowers and when there in this
big final battle here with this giant volcano
she changes the volcanic rock into small birds.
Phastos became the inspiration for the Greek
god Hephaestus because he's an engineer.
He makes things Sprite became the inspiration
for pan, who sort of like the Greek god of
nature, but also because a lot of mischief,
because of her ability to create complex illusions
Gilgamesh is based on the epic hero from the
Sumerian story.
The epic of Gilgamesh later during Babylonian
times.
They wrote a more complex version of the stories
based on him.
He was an epic warrior who just performed
a lot of great deeds five great battles this
battle scene here seems like it's inside the
legendary walls of ancient Babylon before
it fell seen a became the inspiration for
the Greek got a Athena goddess of wisdom and
warfare.
Because she's all about warfare and battle
planning she's the best strategist on the
team and she fights that wicked celestial
pole arm Kingo and Druig aren't associated
with any particular gods the because Kingo
does spends so much time in India.
He might've become the inspiration for some
of the Hindu gods drew again.
In the comics Druig also spent a lot of time
in Eastern Europe so he
could become the inspiration
for a lot of the Slavic gods.
Kro the leader of the deviants became the
inspiration for the Greek Titan Kro knows
and you see how their real story actually
got turned into Greek mythology.
So the whole story of the Titans is that they
came first before the Greek gods within the
context of the MCU the celestials sent the
deviants to earth before they created the
Eternals once the deviants are going rogue
and killing off humans threatening the celestials
plan.
They created the Eternals to go and get rid
of the deviants so plays and a lot of the
tales about how the Greek gods came along
later and then trapped the titans down in
Tartarus like the Eternals trapped Kro and
the other deviants underneath the earth.
Tartarus is also this really primordial place.
So it could be associated with this giant
volcano here where it also seems like the
new celestial is critical emerging from like
we talk about the emergence of a mention the
trailers.
And I know I said a lot of these characters
are the inspiration for Greek gods their home
base was in Olympia in Greece for a long time.
There are actual Greek gods like Zeus and
Hercules in the marvel universe to get a little
confusing in their actually doing Zeus in
the MCU.
So they might do Hercules eventually to Zeus
is being played by Russell Crowe of all people
he is like a big celebrity cameo in Thor love
and thunder.
But I think is probably only going to be in
the movie for a little while.
Because of what they're doing with Christian
Bale's Gorr the god butcher character.
So he might come along and kill Russell Crowe's
Zeus and they just have a really cool short
battle scene kit harington's black knight
character obviously was in the inspiration
for any kind of Greek gods or anything like
that his family originates from the Sir Percy
black knight during the King Arthur Camelot
era in history and King Arthur was a real
person in the marvel universe Camelot was
a real place to the legends about him and
his family mostly come from medieval history.
The be a little more
confusion about his character.
I still see people leaving comments thinking
that he's one of the Eternals kit harington's
Dane Whitman black knight is not one of the
eternal see just a character who gets caught
up in a their craziness and through his adventures
with them.
Search learn more about his heritage as the
black knight I'm sure is marvel Sersi get
more cosmic in especially during Thor love
and thunder.
They'll be so many more questions about gods
inside the MCU.
Like who the most powerful gods.
What about the one above all will probably
get a trailer for Thor love and thunder sometime
early next year if we don't get one before
the end of the year the movies coming out
right after Doctor Strange multiverse of madness.
So to be fun to see which other gods from
the MCU.
They include in that movie.
Just have Christian Bale's Gorr running around
slaughtering them all is not a good time in
the MCU to be a God.
So everyone press up in the chat to pay respects
to them.
But as any big questions you have that I didn't
address in the video just right them blown
the comments and I'll add than the my future
bonus videos everyone click here for my brand-new
Thor love and thunder first look breakdowns
and click here for my other big eternal's
avengers trailer video.
Thank you so much for watching everyone stay
safe and I'll see you guys the next one!